[Music]
hello and welcome to my talk on flimsy
feminism
i hope there are men listening as well
as women because that's
part of what i'm talking about what do i
mean by
flimsy feminism what i mean is that
a lot of us almost all of us i hope now
believe that women are in every respect
equal to men that they are just as
competent
just as intelligent just as expert as
men but do we
actually put those beliefs into practice
in our everyday interactions with women
even something as
trivial as you see a man and a woman
standing together
and you go up to talk to them and you
just automatically address the man first
now that's a very small example but i'm
going to talk about the ways in which
we don't really practice what we preach
or what we believe
when it comes to feminism here's a
classic example of it
which i think a lot of women will
recognize doesn't that happen so often
you're an expert in something you talk
to a man about it
and he tells you what is actually the
case okay it's the offer name is
mansplaining
now i call this the authority gap we all
know about the gender
pay gap and all sorts of other gaps
between men and women but this is
possibly the mother of all gaps the
authority gap
and it's the implicit assumption that a
man knows what he's talking about until
he proves otherwise
while so often for women it's the other
way around
so define my terms authority what do i
do i immediately look at the oxford
online dictionary and i do a screenshot
for you
and it tells us that authority is about
having power over other people
and also being an authority on a subject
in other words having expertise
but what killed me when i looked at this
and it wasn't what i was looking for in
the first place
was that every single example they give
begins with a pronoun
he so we have he had absolute authority
over his subordinates
he has the natural authority of one who
is used to being obeyed
he hit the ball with authority and he
was an authority on the stock market
i mean as if margaret thatcher didn't
have the natural authority of one who
was used to being obeyed or serena
williams doesn't hit the ball with
authority or
helena morrissey isn't an expert on
authority on the stock market i mean
sometimes your subject just
comes up and slaps you in the face how
we associate
men with authority and how we are much
more uncomfortable
associating women with authority and
that is
a very uh important example of the
flimsy feminism i'm
trying to illustrate here so in the
course of researching the book that i'm
writing
which is going to be called the
authority gap i have interviewed about
50 women who are
right at the very very top of their game
so the most authoritative women i could
come across
and you might ask yourself well why is
she talking to them what have they got
to teach
us about this lack of respect for
women's authority and
my thinking was if even they have
experienced the authority gap
if they even they have experienced these
phenomena of not being respected as much
not being listened to as much being
ignored being interrupted
being talked over and surely that proves
that it's true
for the rest of womankind so here's an
example francis morris she is
one of the most powerful not just women
in the art world but people in the art
world globally
she's director of tate modern and she
said to me as director of tate modern
i can spend all day as a powerful
articulate person who's taken seriously
and i can leave this building and i'm
nobody because there's a woman in the
world out there
i'm not taken seriously i'm very often
in situations where people who don't
know my job
and my hand is shaken after the hand of
a male colleague
my eyes are met after the eyes of my
husband are met and no interest is shown
in my opinion
if it's just my opinion as a late
middle-aged female
and i see all that because it's in stark
contrast with the way i'm approached and
treated when it's known that i'm the
director of tank mode
so of course i said to her well maybe
that happens to male directors of tate
modern too if people don't know what
their job is
oh no she said i've worked for three
male directors of tate martin
and it hasn't happened to them i think
that's a fantastic example
of the authority gap now
i'm sure a lot of women have had this
experience you're at a meeting
you come up with a suggestion nobody
takes a blind bit of notice
until a man makes exactly the same
suggestion and everyone says brilliant
idea
should be rao i talked to she's former
treasurer of alphabet which is the
parent company of google
big job right and she said you have to
constantly prove yourself over and over
again
when a guy says something at a meeting
the others will say yeah that sounds
great i think we should do it
and a woman says something they'll say
oh well i think we should look into it
i think we need more data i think we
need to think about that i don't know if
it's really going to work
she says i get challenged a lot
constantly and it's become a way of life
now one form that the authority gap
takes
is being interrupted so you are an
authority on a subject
and somebody usually a man i'm afraid to
say and this isn't prejudice this is
that
simply interrupts you and talks over you
now that is an incredible it's
incredibly undermining of your authority
first of all it suggests that he thinks
what he's got to say is much more
interesting than what you've got to say
and secondly it is literally silencing
you if he's talking over you
so here was a study done by some social
psychologists and they looked at
31 conversations a third between two men
a third between two women and the third
between a man and a woman
and in the first two put together there
were only seven interruptions
in the third one the mixed sex group
there were 48
46 of them by a man now
i mean this is obviously incredibly
striking but it is quite an old study
it's several decades old
so i thought i wonder if that's still
the case so i then found a study done
only a few years ago of 10 000 hours of
oral
transcripts of oral proceedings in the
u.s supreme court
you don't get more authoritative than
being a us supreme court justice right
here's the fabulous
ruth bader ginsburg it turns out that
women make up only a third of the
justices
that have to suffer two-thirds of all
interruptions so in other words they are
four times more likely to be interrupted
than the men on the supreme court
and 96 of those interruptions were by
men
now another interesting facet of this is
talking time
now the urban myth is oh women talk much
more than men do
actually it's not true if you like
somebody up for the day
and you measure men and women how many
words they say in the course of the day
it's pretty much the same but it is
certainly true that
in public when it comes to sort of
expatiating
men tend to bang on for longer than
women i often call it conversational man
spreading
um there was a lovely example here where
researchers gave groups of men and women
um a cassette to talk into so yes
slightly old-fashioned
and three paintings of jura to look at
and then they were asked to talk for as
long as they liked about what they saw
and liked or disliked about these
paintings
on average women talked for 3.17 minutes
men talked on average for four times as
long 13 minutes
but even that wasn't accurate because
three of the men were still talking when
their cassette tapes and 30-minute
cassette tapes
ran out um but i think a possibly a more
interesting study was done
where the researchers put men and women
into small groups of i think eight
people in each group and they were asked
to come up with a solution to a sort of
town hall problem about whether to raise
taxes to spend more money on local
services
and they found that in almost every um
mixture of men and women so they they
had groups that were all men
one woman two women three women four
women or women
in almost every group the women talked
disproportionately less than the men
and for a disproportionate amount of
time so if they made up one-fifth of the
group they talked for less than
one-fifth
of the time except for in two
circumstances one was if women made up
at least 80 percent of the group
and then women talked for a
proportionate amount of time
but interestingly the second um reason
was when the rules of decision making
would change
so that instead of having to have a
majority agreeing
on the solution had to be everybody it
was unanimity so it was like a jury
trial
and in those cases women spoke up now
what that suggests
is that they only spoke up when they
knew their views had to be listened to
because everyone had to agree on the end
solution
and they knew that otherwise what was
the point frankly
now were they right to be
uh suspicious of whether their views
would be taken into account
i'm very sorry to say that they were
because here's a very interesting study
on influence
bear with me because it's a little bit
complicated but anyway
143 business studies students
roughly half and half male and female
they were given a video to watch and
some
information to read about what to do in
the case of a bushfire
and then they were asked to rank in
order of importance
which objects they should take with them
if they were to make them more likely to
survive
a bushfire and it might have been a
torch or a blanket or whatever
now there is an official ranking of
order of importance for these items
and so their answers were measured
against the official ranking to see
how well they did and how many of these
they sort of got right
it turned out women were just as good at
men as men doing this task
and they were actually just as confident
of their ability as men
and then the researchers put them into
groups and in each group they put one
very high scoring person who they deemed
to be an expert
now the group didn't know who that
expert was and the expert didn't know
who they were
what was the result women exerted less
influence within their groups than men
so in other words if you compared the
women's initial ranking with the ranking
the group finally coalesced on
there was more disparity between the
women's and the men's
female experts were perceived as less
expert
than female non-experts and they exerted
significantly
less influence than the non-experts
which sounds really weird doesn't it
but i'll explain why whereas the male
experts were significantly
more influential than the male
non-experts
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you